[Music]
that was of calculation
easily dominating his rivals winning
game after game the opposition has never
been as heated
as prc most
hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony
of the five combined u.s
chess championships an incredible
october that we will
all remember i am maurice ashley
and it was a thrill to call this event
with these great players who played
i certainly want to thank jennifer
shahadi and yasser sarawan who
we had the opportunity to call it and as
you see here the five champions
on screen right now the winners
of the event simply incredible
but before we go any further i would
like to introduce someone whose
generosity has been wonderful throughout
the years
and she has certainly been a part of the
team that has warmed our hearts
so to say a few words i'd like to
introduce dr
jeanne sinksfield
well the us chess sure is doing well
five great tournaments with great
players
and we even had no no technical
difficulties
you know maybe the commentators were
sort of irritated that they didn't get
free lunches every day but otherwise
things were fine
and uh no one sold their sushi you know
i also wanted a little
shout out to some of the people who sent
a little email about my learn to read
and write
chess booklet you know and it was fun
it's nice to see that people are going
to use that to teach
kids and adults i mean i've had waiters
use it and seven-year-olds teach
five-year-olds so
we can increase the number of literate
kids
if i can become literate anything is
possible
in the future we obviously hope to play
in person
because you have to admit it's much
more fun i think to play in person but
really you guys to be able to go online
learn a new technology
play this was spectacular you know and
just a shout out to the audience
we hope you enjoyed this you know this
is a non-profit
we're not making money to do this and we
hope that you really enjoy it if you did
send an email or a twitter you like what
we're doing and any comments you have
and so i guess i should get off and then
maybe you can talk to
rex the godfather of american chefs
bye-bye
well thank you so much genie for those
words and yes absolutely
this was played online and yeah we
missed the free lunches
yeah nobody gets to steal our sushi and
we could have mailed it in but this was
a special
experience to be sure and as we see
they're the five
great champions who won this event but
we're going to start off
with the very first event that took
place and that was the girls
junior i want to show you some
highlights from the event after you see
this great lineup
just incredibly talented young ladies
who played in this event it was a thrill
to be sure
let's take a look at some of the
highlights
the 2020 u.s championship season kicked
off with the girls tournament
where 10 of the nation's best young
female players
competed online for the first time in
history on day one annie wang took the
early lead
after beating reigning women's champion
jennifer yu but on day two karissa yipp
upended the leader to take over the top
spot
and then ran the table with three wins
in a row on the final day
to dominate the event by a point and a
half carissa took home the three
thousand dollar first place prize
and 6 000 in scholarships while annie
wang won two thousand dollars for second
place
and fourteen-year-old rachelle wu 1500
for third
the tournament was a fantastic beginning
to the exciting series of events to come
and we have with us karissa yip the
winner of the 2020 girls junior
junior championship karissa
congratulations once again
what do you remember most about this win
[Music]
it seems carissa we're having a little
difficulty carissa is hearing as karissa
are you hearing hear you hearing me yeah
sorry i just started hearing you
so um congratulations and i want to ask
you
what do you remember most about this win
of yours um
i mean i'll probably remember this for
the rest of my life just because you
know
it was such special circumstances
and um i mean it was a really great win
too i feel like that i played
pretty good for most of the event and so
yeah
i'm pretty proud of my play
you won by a point and a half did you
expect to do that well you had a very
competitive
bunch of players you were up against um
yeah i feel like this field is the
strongest that's been for
quite a few years so i
really wasn't sort of expecting to do as
well as i did
but um i mean it's a pleasant surprise
you've got years ahead of you you won
three
in a row 20 21 looking to make it a
fourth
uh i sure hope so up until i turn 20 and
i can't play anymore
well we expect to see you in many more
to come
congratulations once again on a
fantastic event
thank you karissa yip
came in first place as we see the final
standings annie wang
took second and the youngster rochelle
woo
they're all young but certainly rochelle
showed her stuff
in that one and she has many of those
left to come a very talented field
congratulations to
all the participants we will expect to
see them
many more times in the future but we're
going to move on to someone we've seen
many times
none other than the godfather of chess
as
his wife always calls him let's bring to
the stage a man who needs no
introduction
rexingfield
oh my apologies we're going to first
introduce tony rich
the executive director of the chess club
i see how it is marie should just leave
me out every chance that you get but
that's okay we'll still be friends after
all this is over
um i've prepared some remarks i'd like
to share with everybody man what a what
an exciting month of chess
i'll start by congratulating our new
champions carissa yip
john burke joel benjamin irina crush
and wesley and a big thanks to all the
participants for giving it their all
over the last month i really mean it
when i say
we missed having you here in person and
can't wait for it to be back uh over the
board
i'll also quickly thank all the folks
who make this possible
everyone knows and loves our
commentators yasser sarawan jennifer
shahadi maurice ashley
and this year we also were joined by
christian carrillo
but the team also includes more than 30
individuals behind the scenes that make
it all possible
in particular i'd like to thank the
arbiting staff led by chris bird
i'm lucky to get to work with all of you
regularly and i'd like to thank you for
everything that you do to make it all
possible
so instead of focusing on the things
that we miss about these persons when
they're
these events when they're in person i'll
focus instead on some of the things that
maybe were better this year
over the course of 17 days of play we
were able to award
330 000 in prize money
that's nearly 20 000 a day it was fun
watching all the different facial
expressions that we don't normally get
to see
it was kind of an intimate look into
what it's like to play in these
prestigious events
for the good and the bad uh there was
more chess than typical
with the classical formats from years
past we'd see one round a day
a day and this year we had three rounds
a day roughly 16 games
including john burke's playoff games
there were 270
individual games played that's quite
quite a lot of chess
maybe one of the other positives was the
commute for some of these players i mean
really it was just from
bed to desk and then back to bed at the
end of the day and finally the rapid
format
meant fighting chess surprising upsets
and exciting finales so maurice
i think i'll introduce rex now over the
last 12 years
i've had the pleasure of introducing him
quite a few times now you know the same
fields have been generous in the world
of chess but you may not have realized
that through their support over the last
12 years the st louis chess club has
been able to award nearly 8.5 million
dollars in prize money
and that 8.5 million dollars is just the
tip of the iceberg
you know it doesn't include dr genium
rexingfield's support of the us olympiad
teams
of the world team championship teams it
doesn't include support of the top
junior players through the young stars
program with gary kasparov it doesn't
include the world chess hall of fame and
i could go on and on and on but i know
rex is sitting there telling me to hurry
up
not only has rex change the face of
american chess today
but his legacy will be felt for the next
100 years or more too
now rex is latin for king so join me in
welcoming the king of american chess
rex infield
evening uh what an amazing and wonderful
month
of incredible chess and watching
54 players compete for their titles in
their championship fields
i want to congratulate all of the
players although it's been an
interesting year
i'm thrilled we're able to host all of
the championships online
and special thanks to our great
commentators jennifer maurice and yasser
for the amazing commentary they are
without doubt the best
commentary team in any sport in the
world
and a special thanks to randy and his
teams at spectrum and silverback studios
for all of their hard work throughout
the month and for giving us a great show
and thank you joy tony and the staff of
the chess club
for all your efforts and support in
making this championship series possible
we look forward to seeing all of you in
2021
we hope in person at the chess club in
the newly expanded tournament halls
until then stay safe and be healthy
thank you
thank you so much rex for all that you
do for u.s
chess and indeed as tony said your
impact will be felt
for decades and decades and decades to
come
and tony you know i love you so don't
even try it
we're moving on now to the junior
championship and
what an event that was indeed
you see the best and the brightest of
junior chess
in the united states but not just the
united states seven
of these 10 players are top 100
in the world for the junior level
so an extraordinary field and what a
combative event it indeed was
let's take a look at what went down at
this year's junior championship
the 2020 u.s junior championship
featured 10 of the nation's best young
players
which includes seven of the world's top
100 under the age of 20.
it was a wild affair as top c jeffrey
young seemed to have the pole position
locked up
only to be caught at the end after a
spirited comeback by john burke
their epic tiebreak match went all the
way to armageddon
where despite being ahead a queen and a
rook zhang lost on time
making burke the unlikely winner of the
title the six thousand dollar first
place prize
and six thousand dollars in scholarship
money zhang's second place finish needed
him four thousand dollars
while sam savion gained three thousand
for third in a dramatic championship
that will be remembered for years to
come
and we have with us the junior champion
john burke john congratulations once
again
has it sunk in yet that you did indeed
upset
all the prognosticators and win this
event
yeah um thank you first of all and um
yeah by now it feels like a million
years ago
i don't know when i went into the
tournament i
wasn't really expecting anything of
course i knew jeffrey and sam were the
big favorites
but i figured um so what let's just play
and
see what happens and uh
it worked out in the end i guess it did
work out and that tie break was epic
i mean insane did your nerves recovered
did you get a chance to look at that
like real time to see how it went down
yeah i did go back and look at it but
it's funny like in the heat of the
moment in the playoff games
i thought i would be nervous but i
really wasn't
uh i was kind of just zoned out in a way
and
and i was just playing i was like in a
fog like in a daze or something
and um and yeah when i i checked back
over again of course um there there were
mistakes but
overall i was i was happy that i was
able to at least
keep my composure under the pressure and
i was able to win in the end
what does it mean to you to win this
event and also
to qualify for the 2021 invitational
uh u.s championship it means
so much to win this event um first of
all this is something i didn't even
realize until recently i guess
this is my last time playing this one
and because i'm 19
now and i guess i'm getting too old
which
is sort of surprising to me because i i
think the first time i played i was 17
um and i didn't even qualify for this
tournament until i was
already a gm and that goes to show how
strong it is
and um to be able to win in my last try
is
really it's something that means a lot
to me
and of course to be able to play in the
u.s championship
well that was kind of the main incentive
like titles and money of course it's
nice and stuff
but the ability to to finally get the
chance to
to play against all these great players
not only the best in the us but
in the world as well that really means
the world and
i'm looking forward to it a lot because
there's really going to be no pressure
on me i'm just going to try to enjoy the
experience
and and take it all in basically and
yeah it's it's going to be really
exciting and i'm looking forward to it
and shock the world the way you shocked
us all this time around
congratulations it is surprising that
you are leaving
the tournament along with your fellow
competitors a couple of 19 year olds are
turning 20 as well
but you did your thing on your last try
once again much success and
congratulations
thank you and let's look at the
standings as a matter of fact
we commentators missed that little fact
about john burke
that this was his last try as he took
first place
this was jeffrey jean's last try as he
turns 20 tomorrow
and it was also sam savion's last try
as he will turn 20 in december
so they made the most of this
championship
coming in first second and third
and we expect to see them in the future
i think all three of them
will probably qualify as a matter of
fact to the u.s championship itself
in 2021 so the future is bright for
junior chess in the united states
well speaking of chess united states we
have a lady who runs the ship the of the
us chess federation
the executive director carol meyer
it's always a little bittersweet when
special events come to an end
despite the unusual nature of this
year's championships
that bittersweet feeling is no different
what a whirlwind of chess for the past
three weeks
crowning new champions across the
spectrum of events and ages
congratulations to all the winners for
your great games and achievements
beating your very talented peers in the
process
of course congratulations to all the
players who are invited to compete
you are among the best players us chess
has to offer
our thanks to the st louis chess club
for running five fabulous events
to chief tournament director chris byrd
and his assistants
and to all those involved with making
the events possible
of course u.s chess is grateful to
jeannie and rex singfield
for their continued commitment to
supporting the best chess in the united
states
with their vision they have transformed
the us championships into the premier
national championships
in the world i look forward to the time
when we can be together again
enjoying the camaraderie and friendships
that the game brings
until then be well
thank you carol well 20 to 30 years ago
there were very different faces in these
u.s championships
and we got a chance to see these great
legends
play in this event and look at those
faces
i remember growing up idolizing these
incredible players
champions all also playing for the
olympic teams the olympians
just incredible players and they regaled
us with some great chess
in this event let's take a look back at
the usc
the 2020 senior championship brought
together many of the legends of u.s
chess who came to rekindle their old
rivalries from days gone by
it was an intense battle early on as
both igor novikov and joel benjamin took
a slim lead
ahead of a bunched up field after the
first day things looked bad for benjamin
when he lost to dmitry gurovich in round
four
but some powerful play the rest of the
way gave him an amazing point-and-a-half
victory
as well as the distinction of being the
first in history to win the u.s junior
u.s championship and the u.s senior
titles
the great gladiators from decades past
show that they still have what it takes
to play fantastic chess
[Music]
and we are with fellow brooklynite
joel benjamin joel congratulations
on your event could you have imagined
when you lost that game to dmitry that
you would actually win the tournament
by a point and a half against this field
well under no circumstances did i think
that i could
win this tournament by a point and a
half uh
after that game i just thought oh no
what you can't let this get away
i just got to calm down i played as
simply as possible in the next round
traded off went into the end game and i
put that point away
and then i was uh back on track for the
rest of the event
indeed you were and i made mention of
the fact in that
that clip that you won the u.s junior
invitational the u.s
championship three times and now this
event what does that mean to you
well it's funny because when you when
you mentioned it
uh in the interview after the the event
i i hadn't
thought about that at all but you know
now that it's
it's sinking in i think like you know
that's
that's a pretty a pretty good
achievement you know it's
it's one of those things i could never
take away from you so uh
i'm pretty proud of that record indeed
you should be here the first in history
to do it that will be forever as well
looking forward to next year already
2021 maybe in person next time
absolutely it's it's uh wonderful to
compete against this great bunch of guys
and uh it's even better if we could do
it in person
so hopefully things will get better and
we'll be able to do that next year
indeed well congratulations joel on a
great event
indeed a special result and you were the
champion
congrats thank you very much maurice
and we see the final standings in front
of us as
joel did win by an amazing point and a
half taking home
twelve thousand dollars for that victory
and the three legends as well
tied for second gregory cardano igor
novikov and
dmitry gurevich taking home 667
for their brilliant performance
and now to introduce a special event
that will be taking place on december
1st the st
louis campus does so much they
have literally changed the face of
american chess and
they're going to have an event that i
love to attend every single year because
it's just a feel-good event
and it gives us an opportunity to
support an institution that has helped
my career careers of other commentators
and players
as well so much it's an important part
of
what happens in st louis and what
happens in the united states
so please if you can attend please do
and listen to a few words about the
fundraiser
strategy across the board
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame
and legendary world chess champion gary
kasparov
invites you to attend strategy across
the board the virtual fourth annual
gala a fundraiser to advance saint louis
through the artistic
cultural and educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
[Music]
again a wonderful event there
no question and another wonderful event
the 2020
u.s women's championship as you see
the finest women in america players
brilliant players all who competed and
what
and show it was this one was special
folks
and here are some of the highlights
the 2020 u.s women's championship once
again brought together legendary
champions
and young talents looking to cement
their names in history
annie wang took the lead on day one but
irena crush karissa yip
and dorsa derek shani played blistering
chess over the next two days
to set up a dramatic race to the finish
in the end crush was able to win her
last two games
in dominating fashion to not only gain
the 25 000
first place prize but to also notch her
eighth championship title
leaving her just one short of giselle
aggressor's all-time record
it was yet another year where the top
women in the country regale their fans
with inspiring chess
[Music]
and we saw that double fistfum from
grandmaster irena crush
fellow brooklynite i can also mention
something special about
the water here in brooklyn irena are you
still glowing from this eighth title
it really was a special one for you
yeah well i was very happy about it
maurice it was definitely
um a little bit unexpected you know
because when i was asked about my goal
for the tournament
um i said uh to not be too embarrassing
so i think i managed to clear that that
bar is happy about that
i think you more than clear that bar
absolutely but it is true
you have played four championships
before this and not won any of them
when you were winning them left and
right you and anna were just dominating
what made this one so different
um well i think i uh maybe prepared a
little bit differently
um i took some time off of work you know
to prepare
last week and a half um i took advice of
alex honestly he told me a long time ago
you know you gotta
you cannot just jump from your kind of
crazy life in new york to to these
championships and um and i and i
uh took some rest before this tournament
um
but i think maurice you know i really
wanted to use this opportunity to uh to
thank some people if you allow me
please do okay so first of all
um you know usually when you win a
tournament you thank the people you know
who are involved in your success and you
know in this tournament and
um but i want to really thank the chess
community in general um
you know because they were supporting me
uh way before this tournament started
this year
um you know when i wrote my first uh
post on facebook back in march
um i was really thinking just to let you
guys know like firsthand you know what
this experience uh with kovid was like
and i was really not expecting this huge
outpouring of support
from people um all over the world um
in the chess community you know wishing
me well wishing me
uh my recovery and actually i got like a
definitely a boost from that a
psychological boost as i was struggling
through that
um to know that people just wanted me uh
to do well there were people who
offered to uh send me turmeric that was
mike klein people who
wanted to to send me dinners at home
that was mike and melik and just
count countless people and um
and yeah i really felt like i was
supported not just by
my family and close friends in that time
but like by my whole
uh chess community but my chest family
as i see it
um so first of all thank you to all of
you guys i didn't get to
get a chance to thank many of you there
were just two too many people
um but i definitely appreciated that
i wanted to to thank one more person who
i forgot to thank in the
post-game interview that's my friend
alex lenderman
um he's someone who's always been very
supportive of my chess
whether he's helping me prepare in the
olympiads or other big tournaments
or beating me in countless blitz games
you know in the effort to make me a
little bit better at blitz chess
you know i could always count on alex um
to to uh give me his support
i'd like to thank my coach uh who
i don't know if you guys know but um in
all the six titles i've won in st
louis he's uh he's been with me through
all of those championships um
and of course you can't really see him
you know he's in the background doing
his work but i can tell you that in
every
and every big decision um in every
moment that the championship was on
on the line over these years uh you know
we did it together
and um our teamwork is what has won
these championships
and finally maurice i'm coming to
something important you said today
uh in your interview with wesley you
mentioned to wesley like
hey uh wesley aren't you surprised that
you know you won forty thousand dollars
the prize fund was not decreased at all
um you know for this online tournament
and you asked him what he thought about
that and so i want to tell you
what i thought about that um you know
when i found out there was going to be a
championship it was going to be online
i was very happy i was like wow we are
just going to
get the same prize fund you know for
playing a lot less days
and this was before the prize fund was
announced you know and i was talking
with my friend he was like no you know
the price was going to be decreased of
course you know you're playing fewer
days of chess
i was like no i don't think so i don't
you know and why was i so confident in
this thing because
of course it would be logical to
decrease the prize fund of course you
know we were playing fewer days
from home um but you know 10 years of
being part of the st louis experience of
watching how you guys um
you know handle these events and treat
chess players i was thinking okay if st
louis has a choice
they're going to go with the choice that
is more generous with the players
and therefore i was not really surprised
at all that this prize fund stayed the
same
but one thing that i did learn that was
new
and just a couple of days ago uh you
know i found out that actually that
decision
uh was was given um from higher from
higher up that
you know when presented with a different
prize fund um
our sponsor rex was like well uh why why
the lower price fund you know we
uh the players need to make a living and
so rex you know i just wanted to say
thank you i mean that doesn't surprise
me
about what well you did rex but it does
make me very happy
um because you're not just a sponsor you
are a true friend to chess players
um and we love you we miss you and uh we
cannot wait to see you again in st
louis um so i think you know i'm close
to being done maurice i'm sorry for that
i just wanted to get all of that
out to you guys um and you know
uh in terms of what makes this
tournament special i think
what makes it special is where i started
this year out from
you know um from the position that i was
in back in march
where you know i couldn't breathe and i
was driving myself to the emergency room
multiple times you know at midnight at 2
a.m you know
hoping that um there wouldn't be like a
10 hour wait to see a doctor
and to go from that low moment to uh
getting my eighth title in the same year
that makes me really happy well thank
you so much we can see how much it means
to you
that your resiliency was what
made you a champion in the first place
to be able to do it in such a
challenging circumstance
was absolutely admirable and
inspirational we thank you for all those
kind words
again congratulations irena on your
eighth
championship and it was not just irina
at the top as well as though she did win
but she was
chased by a couple of
really enterprising players particularly
karissa yiff
who was nipping at her heels all the way
there they had to win their last couple
of games and carissa did that as well
took second place don't forget carissa
won
the girls junior and came in second at
this
event simply a fabulous result and
dorset derek shani the lowest rated
player in the event
did show a great performance and came in
third place well
a gentleman who needs absolutely no
introduction if i started listing
all his accomplishments i'd be here for
at least three hours
but he's been a friend to us chess all
these years
and certainly a friend to st louis
please
everyone enjoy these words by
none other than the 13th world champion
gary caspara
hello again from croatia to the many
parts of the us
and the globe all the players and fans
find themselves in these strange times
my congratulations to all the champions
a word that one never grows tired of
hearing
i wish we could be together to celebrate
the winners and to console the losers
something that champagne is good for in
both cases
this year virtual congratulations will
have to be enough
and each of you will celebrate or drown
your sorrows
as you see fit but it's important to
have come together in this way
to be together in spirit to be together
in chess
because that has always been the
greatest strengths of our beloved game
it's a community connected across the
world
like a mighty chain of pawns
chess goes back centuries from oriental
palaces to european coffee houses and
now
to zoom and netflix the game adapts
because the players adapt the sponsors
adapt
and chess keeps growing its beauty
is innate eternal even as the
environment changes around it
chess has given us all so much
and all of you playing watching and
supporting the us championships
are giving back so congratulations
and thanks again to rex and genie and
all the players for sharing their love
of chess with us all
in these difficult times i look forward
to seeing you
in person soon but for now
my heart and all our hearts are instead
loose
thank you gary and we certainly look
forward to seeing you soon as well
you're in croatia but your spirit always
transcends all boundaries
and your inspiration has been wonderful
for so many chess players
so many chess fans around the world well
we come now to the final event that took
place in october
and again what an event it was
it just seemed like the players were
bringing it each and
every day and we see here the best
players
in the united states taking part in the
2020 u.s championship
and the highlights were spectacular and
some history
was made take a look at these highlights
the 2020 u.s chess championship saw the
best players
in the country take center stage to
close out in october to remember
2017 champion wesley so started out in
spectacular fashion
with a score of 5-0 but jeffrey zhang
and ray robinson stayed right behind him
with blistering performances of their
own soul finally managed to shake his
nearest rivals
by defeating zhang in round nine and
with two solid draws to close things out
he cemented an amazing score of 9 out of
11
tying none other than bobby fischer for
the third best score in event history
it was an exciting end to a memorable
month of
championship chess
and we are with wesley so and i see a
couple of people
snuck in there over your shoulder wesley
congratulations to you and your family i
know you got a great
support system absolutely wesley
how sweet is it to have won this event
no it means a lot to me as being a big
deal uh
yeah i was actually looking up i have
three trophies here from my past
us championships and i think 2016
i finished the third and then first
and then second and then third so i
thought
that i would never be able to win it
again but
now i finally did it this means a lot
this uh
this title is very prestigious and it
means a lot to me
needed some luck a bit in the end but uh
with jeffrey playing so well also
it was a very very tough tournament
uh there are two people who pitch you to
win the event on our commentating team
so
nobody is surprised that you won wesley
you played great chess but as you
mentioned
you were really pressed by ray
and jeffrey what did it take in the end
to
eke this one out yeah i was thinking
about
it actually uh uh jeffrey
really played out of this world in this
tournament and
uh in my game against him i needed to
trick him in the last few seconds
uh because it should have ended in a
draw
but truly told he was very low on time
but if he drew that game
uh then he the title would most likely
go to him so uh needs a bit of fortune
in the end
but uh very happy to get this title and
i actually like to
thank a lot of people if you could just
me
please do and start by introducing the
family who
clearly is a support system behind you
yeah i know
it's my own poster mother ladies
abigail
yeah they've been so very supportive to
me it's very unfortunate that
we all have to do this online i would
very much prefer to
to get back over the board in fact we
had the poll a few months ago
there's in the u.s champs once
wanted to do it over the board and i
think we were one of the few ones who
said yes
and it's really unfortunate because st
louis is like a second home to me and
second home to us
so to not be able to go there for
for more than a year it's very
heartbreaking really
uh i know joy said that they've been
upgrading the club
and they've been improving it a lot so
i'm very excited to be able to travel
i'm really hoping that the uf
championships will be
held over the board next year uh yeah
this
this corn virus is uh very unfortunate
but
uh but that's life i just hope it goes
away soon
uh well i'd like to thank first of all
our sponsors of course rex and jeannie
thinksfield
for being also generous and i'd like to
thank
usgs federation for
uh hosting this uh this event uh it's
it's actually a big deal to not to not
skip this year
this year's u.s championships i thought
for a moment
that they would skip it but fortunately
they didn't
and uh i'd like to thank all the people
who made this possible
to chris bird and to the arbiters for
doing great job
i'd like to thank tony rich and joy bray
for working so hard behind the scenes
and i'd like to thank the production
staff also
to kevin duggan those guys
and uh yeah also to
again to the commentators to the three
of you uh
maurice yasser and jennifer
uh you you bring such uh
such pleasure and joy uh keeping us
entertained
and also i'd like to congratulate my
fellow winners
uh john burke carissa uh
irena of course and
and joel benjamin was actually
one of my favorite players growing up
and also yeah i'd like to thank my my
family here
for being so supportive and uh
you like the same message
i guess we're really really grateful to
genie
because like they said they didn't have
to hold
the championships this year it would
have been very acceptable i guess
to just say no it's too complicated and
but you put like this great big kiss on
the end of a very difficult year for
wesley
and i think we're all very grateful for
that
well indeed we are grateful to you all
we know it takes a family we're all a
big family
and you are always supporting wesley
wesley congratulations on a performance
for the ages
your performance is tied with none other
than bobby fisher's
when you start putting names like that
so performance you know that it was
special so
congrats my friend and look forward to
seeing you in 2021
again the final standings we see here
wesley so
nine points out of 11.
that's a plus seven that's obscene he
did win forty thousand dollars for that
victory
jeffrey zhang kept the pace it was their
one-on-one match-up that really decided
the entire championship as wesley was
able to beat jeffrey
right at the wire jeffrey with a
fantastic score
of eight and a half and ray robson also
had very special championships as well
he came in third place and took home
16 000 well
wesley did make mention of the
renovations that are taking place
at the club and we can only hope that
things allow us circumstances allow us
to be back together as a family and say
lois because
there's going to be some wonderful
changes a lot of extra space
let's take a look at the work they're
doing to improve what's already a
fantastic product
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of
all ages as well as expanded tournament
and community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination for lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the sinfield cup st louis rapid and
bullets and more
yes we are looking forward to that for
sure
and let's take a look at the champions
karissa yip
the winner of the girls junior
championship her special performance
will be one to indeed remember a point
and a half ahead of the rest of the
field
and john burke the winner of
the junior championship that epic
matchup
going all the way to the armageddon with
jeffrey xiang was simply
incredible one for the ages and the
seniors
this legend of american chess just
adding
another title to his mental incredible
performance by joel benjamin
he's got the trifecta the first in
history to do that
and the women's champion irina crush
what can you say when you win it eight
times i think that's a future hall of
famer
without a doubt incredible performance
by by irena
and you see she did it in a year when
she and by the way joel benjamin as well
survived kovid and finally wesley sowe
with a scintillating performance for the
ages
incredible results winning his second
title
he might have doubts but we are certain
that
wesley will have more titles in his
future to come
and we get one last look at the
champions
all five well deserved thank you so much
for joining us
it was an incredible month of october
but
everybody's crossing their fingers that
we will all be together again as a
family
in 2021 thanks for joining us everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you